this video is brought to you by rage
shadow legends
what's up guys michael here succession's
long-awaited return is one of this
year's banner events for tv fans
promising another round of roy on roy
action set amidst the lush surroundings
of the economic elites there are lots of
obviously appealing things about this
show it's got a killer cast they're dead
to me
no one goes sniffing around my panties
to viciously funny dialogue well like
could you maybe get a little experience
at like a cvs something yeah or just
like nickel hand jobs under a bridge and
the constant source of excessively tall
entertainment that is cousin greg a
person can fit through there a person
can definitely fit through that window a
small person an attack child it's not
surprising that we're drawn to the life
and times of this ultra rich snake pit
of a family after all hollywood has cut
its teeth making shows and movies that
celebrate how freaking great it is to be
rich and at first glance it might seem
easy to lump succession in with them but
if you look closely at how it depicts
the world of the one percent you'll find
it's doing something very different
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on succession does money make you
miserable and the spoiler alert for the
first two seasons of succession
and before we dive in i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor raid
shadow legends in case you missed it
raid is an awesome hero collector rpg
where you can collect champions and wage
battles against friends or other players
online here at wisecrack we've been
playing raid for a while which means
it's hard to pick a favorite of all the
champions i've collected so far but if i
had to pick my top 5 favorite champions
i'm tempted to go by the coolest names
after all what's in a rose or an arrayed
champion a champion by any other name is
just as powerful for your clan so
without further ado number one masked
fearmon he's friday the 13th themed and
he literally strikes fear into his
opponents case closed number two ursula
the mourner she protects your clan from
damage and increases the damage you deal
out to your opponents at the same time
number three lydia the death siren the
perfect name for a one-person band and
her siren's well skills help you easily
clear the doom tower and collect
artifacts number four sir nicholas
because that's such a cheerful name but
don't be fooled he can also freeze and
debuff your enemies with ease number
five
krisk the ageless because to me
agelessness would rule then again so
would chrisk's centuried vigor which can
protect you and your allies during
crucial battle moments there's always
something new to discover in the game
for instance this month's halloween
lineup lands soon and it includes huge
rewards new tournament options and
special fragment events plus nothing
says spooky season like collecting a new
halloween themed champion which i can't
wait to see and here's a pro tip to help
you when you get started in the game
when you want to level up your champions
try farming the campaign grind your xp
collect silver and artifacts and boom
you're ready to really get into the
action with even more powerful champions
if you want to get a huge head start in
raid all you have to do is hit the link
in the description or scan my qr code
and you'll get an epic hero chanaru who
is amazing in the doom tower 200k silver
one xp boost one energy refill and one
ancient shard so you can summon an
awesome champion as soon as you get in
game i don't know why people say we look
alike i don't see it at all i guess it's
the eyes these rewards are available
only for the next 30 days and only for
new players so click the link in the
description to download the game for ios
android or pc today and now back to the
show it's impossible to talk about
succession without talking about money
because every scene is basically
drowning in dollar signs the roy family
are media moguls styled after the
murdochs who lord over a vast empire
anchored by amusement parks and a
reactionary right-wing news channel you
know waystar waystar royko we do hate
speech in roller coasters as a result
they live in a world that is totally
defined by wealth they wear the finest
suits and take private jets from
luxurious penthouses to countryside
mansions they eat the fanciest food i'm
so
good they drink the fanciest wine hey
greg
what are you
drinking uh this is i'm not sure it's a
it's a rose it's not my favorite they
have extravagant leisure activities
models just throw a grenade at the pigs
every single centimeter of their lives
has been tailor made to ensure they get
only the best of the best taken as a
whole the show paints a picture of what
it looks like to live with all the money
in the world conceptually it's a fantasy
we've seen played out on screen lots of
times before from popular tv series like
dynasty dallas gossip girl billions and
big little lies to hit movies like crazy
rich asians and the wolf of wall street
how the top 1 percent lives is a major
part of our media diet some offer a pure
celebration of excess while some cast a
more critical eye but pretty much all of
them give us the vicarious thrill of
watching the filthy rich play with their
money it's pretty straightforward wish
fulfillment most of us live the majority
of our lives penned in by bank balances
that are never as high as we'd like so
it's no wonder we lust after the idea of
a life where all those limitations just
melt away and we can do whatever we want
all the time look here's the thing
about being rich
okay
it's [ __ ] great
okay it's like being a superhero only
better
you get to do what you want the
authorities can't really touch you you
get to wear a costume but it's designed
by armani there's a term for this wealth
porn which describes media that exists
primarily so we can salivate over
designer clothes and lux apartments
apologies if you thought wealth porn is
when a dude the bag of money the term
was coined by journalist gary poole in
the year 2000. it describes the fawning
news coverage of the uber wealthy in
publications like fortune and forbes the
term caught on which makes sense
considering shows like cribs were at
their peak never forget that tommy lee
had a starbucks in his house tommy lee
has a starbucks in his house cribs baby
watch it like a whole starbucks with
workers and everything shows like
entourage and gossip girl were also
pretty brazen about their desire to
provide exactly this sort of economic
escapism happily framing every angle of
their character's material wealth but
the term wealth porn becomes more loaded
when it's applied to media that's
ostensibly lampooning this excess while
arguably just indulging in it the wolf
of wall street and billions for instance
have both continually divided critics as
to where they fall on the spectrum so
why are we so attracted to stories set
within society's upper crust most
obviously wealth looks really good on
screen from lush apartments to designer
clothes to exotic locales and the
cinematography typically luxuriates in
it cameras whirl to capture the madcap
excess or glide serenely across each
perfectly manicured set but that's not
quite what we get in succession their
apartments might be huge and their
dinners might cost more than any car
i've ever owned but the world of the
roys rarely looks all that desirable
visually this comes from the gorilla
style of the cinematography the show
uses free roaming cameramen to create a
voyeuristic and lo-fi aesthetic this
adds a diy clumsiness to a designer
world it also avoids the indulgent poise
style of most media about the one
percent one of the show's directors mark
milad told indywire that when filming
the roys in any opulent location he
always makes sure the character is
leading the cinematography rather than
having a camera pan lovingly across a
fancy set it's almost an anti-aesthetic
in terms of the craft he says the show
purposely avoids depicting wealth as
synonymous with beauty the frequently
unflattering lighting shows every dark
under eye circle and wrinkle to
perfection and the beige color palette
becomes overwhelming in its blandness as
series creator jessie armstrong
describes their lives are somewhat
denuded of color in short for once being
filthy rich doesn't look filthy sexy
which to be clear isn't the name for a
type of porn where a guy grinds up on a
big pile of dirt and twigs and
importantly the series used on-set
wealth advisors to help the cast fully
inhabit the world of the one percent
grounding it in the day-to-day realism
of life as a rich person the show is
able to effectively de-eroticize the
whole thing well almost the whole thing
brian cox can still get it anytime
anywhere for example one piece of advice
the cast received was about how they
made their way in and out of the
helicopters which the roys use like
ubers you'll notice that none of them
ever duck the way we would expect most
people to that's because when you've
been traveling that way since childhood
it's as natural as stepping onto a train
or climbing into a car which is maybe
why kendall is so comfortable inside a
helicopter that he occasionally tries to
drunkenly pilot one because here's the
thing
if you've been rich your whole life the
idea of being rich just isn't all that
interesting cinderella's stories like
crazy rich asians and ryzen fall tales
like wolf of wall street are so
effective because they give the audience
an avatar who enters the world of the
wealthy with the same doe-eyed wonder as
we would because wealth porn is really
for those of us who will never
experience that kind of opulence or
unfettered freedom in real life in
contrast succession demystifies wealth
the show pulls back the curtain to
reveal the drudgery and degradation
required to create this seamless luxury
like when the roys are getting ready to
have a decadent feast rather than simply
having their tasty treats appear on
screen fully formed the show depicts
every bit of the painstaking work their
staff takes to prepare and serve it and
then logan gets mad about a bad smell
and orders the whole thing destroyed
before a single bite has been eaten and
i don't want all this
that sat around in the stink
pizza we'll have pizza and so we get to
watch that same army of service
employees clear away a few rent checks
worth of hope cuisine and when
succession does show a cinderella story
it's not quite such a whirlwind romance
connor whose best friend is ferris
bueller is initially paying willa to
spend time with him as an escort before
the two of them decide to go steady but
even after the relationship remains
transactional willa shacks up with a
delusional rich guy twice her age
because it's the only realistic hope she
has of funding her own creative
ambitions no matter how ill-advised they
might be you know i don't need to see
the reviews you know i don't care
exactly the play is brilliant who cares
what some
old white dude from the new york times
says it's easy to write willa off as a
sly opportunist but connor is equally
complicit lording his money over her to
get what he wants and that brings us to
the second part of wealth porn's appeal
because it's never just about the pretty
things that money can buy but the power
that comes with it
enough of this will make you invincible
able to conquer the world
and eviscerate your enemies yet another
rich guy who thinks money makes you a de
facto superhero which recent comic book
cinema has confirmed what are your
superpowers again
i'm rich but even if you aren't building
batmobiles or bulletproof armor wealth
gives you immunity from the rules which
govern most people's lives any problem
you encounter can be whisked away in a
flurry of dollar bills even mess-ups
like you know coke-fueled vehicular
homicide you'd have to buy out the
entire cabin and the first-class flight
attendant i bought the airline
it seemed neater there is a somewhat
dangerous appeal in the idea of being so
strong that we can bend the world around
us to our whims and the roys are all
high on this particular power fantasy
one of the great joys of watching
succession is the stiletto sharp
dialogue which turns each conversation
into a knife fight he's sure you'll
understand but he's going to need to
offer an alternative face for this
discussion
alternative face what does that mean
if i drop my pants i can show you an
alternative face how does that sound and
every meeting into a series of vicious
insults and perfectly delivered put
downs pay transparency
bargaining rights just nasty tangly
and it's not a body pit whatever the
body pit is it's a [ __ ] muesli pit
but these scenes are never just there
for us to enjoy the punch lines well
okay maybe occasionally they are tom
it's tough to have to tell you like this
but i'm in a sexual relationship with
your mother
she talks in her sleep but these moments
also give us an insight into what life
at the top is like the roy's brutal way
of talking to one another is a manner of
establishing dominance generally bored
of their extreme wealth the power it
gives them is the real high and it's a
vital part of their identity too they
all have to believe that they are
corporate warriors battering their way
to the top of the food chain through
cunning resilience and ruthlessness in
reality the roys are rarely as
impressive as they think they are they
like to imagine themselves playing
four-dimensional chess as they plot and
scheme their way towards world
domination but the truth is that the
roys are constantly bumping up against
their own shortcomings she thinks she's
smarter than she is
roman could actually be good but um
but nowhere near right now
kendall's
i don't know it's like you put him in a
big diaper and now he can show himself
whenever he likes
he has all the shots but he doesn't want
to play them
kendall is an insecure mess and torn
between a desperation for his father's
approval and a furious desire to take
revenge upon him you have a hard time
finding a happy medium between
worshiping him and wanting to kill him
he's vaguely pathetic even needing a
personal driver for his badass
motorcycle his anxiety leads him to
bungle two separate coup attempts and it
takes nearly losing everything for him
to finally take decisive action roman
has his own inadequacy issues which have
left him emotionally detached and
sexually um
incapacitated
we never [ __ ]
oh yeah we do no we don't he covers this
with an air of abrasive bravado but when
push comes to shove he is still a little
boy terrified of his father
i swear to god that if you bring him
back i am walking
back to my office to
sulk siobhan often seems like the
smartest and most confident sibling but
even she continually overplays her hand
and finds herself caught up in logan's
games oh [ __ ] sake dad just tell him
it's gonna be me and then there's connor
who is so insulated by wealth that he
has effectively lost touch with reality
he's a grown man living out quixotic
fantasies until the money runs out but
you have to quit your campaign and at
the end of the day every one of these
kids just wants a kiss from daddy
the truth is that none of the roys are
the machiavellian geniuses that they
think they are when their plans succeed
it's rarely because they intellectually
outmaneuvered their opponents or
executed some daring scheme it's just
because they are really really rich
because i'm going to stuff your mouth
with so much money you're going to shoot
gold figurines
non-disclosure agreement non-voting
shares non-compete
i'm going to lock you in a golden cage
[ __ ] you with a silver dildo and pay you
so much you sing whatever song i want
clearly kendall imagines himself as the
unstoppable boardroom warrior laying
waste to his enemies and seizing what he
wants in reality he's just a rich kid
playing with his dad's money he wasn't
able to persuade seduce or intimidate
his opponent into a deal so he's just
throwing money at him until he agrees
there's no merit to his victory no proof
of talent or character he wins as the
roys always do simply because of how
rich he is yeah
money wins and that's ultimately who the
roys are and it's why the show is able
to avoid the wealth porn trap which is
what it's called when you think you're
just going to hump some money but then
it turns out it's a trap set by the host
of to catch a predator chris hanson
everything in the roy's life looks
expensive and yet practically none of it
seems desirable it's clear that we
aren't watching the masters of the
universe go about their godly business
instead they're just a bunch of
egocentric insecure [ __ ] lording
their power so that they can feel
important really good effort really
quite tremendous so take this back to
your life it's a quarter million and
even their most extravagant moments tend
to be kind of pathetic they'll buy out
an entire theme park to win back their
children's love thank you for um
closing down the park for us sophie
just having a great birthday she got to
meet snowjoin or barter holidays with
their mother to save their dad a piece
of real estate ultimately all of their
adventures boil down to greedy squabbles
over extra dollars you can threaten to
stuff a million severed dicks into my
ball back but the actual fact is we're
persuading more and more shareholders
every day that we offer them just a
slightly better chance for them to make
a little bit more money on their [ __ ]
dollar and that's all that this is their
world for all its luxurious furnishings
is cold empty and relentlessly petty and
so are they which is kind of what makes
them so compelling we get to see the
broken humanity that they've tried to
paint over in golden leaf the parts of
them that are desperate for acceptance
terrified of failure and haunted by
childhood demons and this is actually
pretty fitting while a lot of us might
equate massive wealth with happiness a
number of studies suggest things are
more complicated there's conflicting
data but one influential study actually
found that money stops quote unquote
buying happiness once you've reached a
75 000 salary what's more a striking
number of billionaires become clinically
depressed upon hitting it big some
researchers think that this is because
material wealth can isolate you from
other people leading you to value
independence over human connection and
that's possibly because owning lots of
fancy
makes you feel more competitive with
those around you this kind of isolation
and lack of human connection is rife
throughout succession we see it in the
jumpy dislocated camera moves in sterile
environments and in the way the
characters treat each other when a
recently sort of kidnapped roman tries
to share his feelings with his siblings
he is roundly mocked for showing even a
trace of vulnerability
feelings
how am i the mature one here we don't
have any feelings what are you talking
about in this way rather than gawking at
their lavish lifestyles or brilliant
power moves the show reveals the
characters deeply damaged cores their
pettiness their jealousy their constant
self-sabotage and there's nothing
pornographic about it however much we
enjoy watching them screw each other i
was from every direction but what do you
guys think does the life of the roys
still look pretty good to you or does
succession have you thinking that maybe
life in the one percent ain't all it's
cracked up to be let us know in the
comments huge thanks to all of our
patrons and be sure to check out our
podcast bear hug that subscribe button
like you're trying to steal your
father's empire and don't forget to ring
that bell and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
you